يستيقظ المتحف الأكثر زيارة في العالم
ولكن لا يوجد زوار هنا
السلالم المتحركة التي كانت تحمل أربعين
ألف زوج من الأقدام يوميًا
صافرة في الفراغ المخيف
الناجم عن القيود المرغوبة
فينوس دي ميلو ليبرتي التي تقود
الناس والموناليزا يحصلون على استراحة
من  الحشود المعتادة من المعجبين
ما كانت المكالمات الصاخبة تستغرق الآن
دقائق فقط للسير عبر
المنحوتات التي أجبرت على السبات في
قصر النهضة هذا ،
لكنهم ليسوا وحدهم تمامًا ،
فهو لا يزال يعيش على الرغم من أنه يبدو
نائمًا حقًا من الخارج منذ أكتوبر
عندما أغلق اللوفر
مئات من  يعمل الحرفيون
خمسة أيام في الأسبوع
لتجديد وتجديد شبابهم
بضربة فرشاة
أو كرنك رافعة شوكية لدينا
جميع الفنون
التي يتم تخزينها أو دراستها للتو من
قبل القيمين على المعرض لدينا
أه جميع أعمال الصيانة التي من
الواضح أنها يمكن  لا أتوقف ،
لذا من المجزي حقًا أن المخاطر
كبيرة جدًا ، دعنا نقول
أنك لا تريد إفساد ما
كان عليه الناس  البناء في قرون
ليس منذ الحرب العالمية الثانية ، تم إغلاق اللوفر
أمام الجمهور لفترة طويلة
في العام الماضي ، حيث خسر 90 مليون يورو من
الإيرادات ،
لكن القيمين هنا يقولون إنهم
اكتسبوا وقتًا أكثر قيمة
[موسيقى]
من أبواب القرن التاسع عشر التي
فتحت من قبل  في غرفة نوم الملوك الفرنسيين
، يتم استعادة جمالهم السابق
ولديك هذه الطبقات المختلفة
التي تهدف إلى إعادة تكوين
كل عروق الخشب
لأنك تعرف الكثير من
الألوان المختلفة
أه عندما تنظر إلى تلك الألوان الاصطناعية عن كثب
سيتم الانتهاء من الأبواب في
غضون ثلاثة أسابيع عندما يعاد فتح
اللوفر.